i-22 combining bingo with exercise is a
good workout for mind and body a great
way to manage the realities of Aging for
the older residents of San Rafael
California if I knew science could
develop something where I could keep my
memory and physical ability to the day I
die I'd be happy with that one yeah
right now science can't offer that but
is it about to healthy ages like
Gretchen are the inspiration for What's
Happening Here in California a boom in
anti-aging research a few things better
embody the pursuit of Eternal youth than
Californian Beach culture you only have
to look around you to see the ravages at
time affect us all differently some
people live healthy lives but Die Young
others go on well beyond their 90s and
it's that fact that's convinced
scientists aging is something we can
prevent like our immune system that
weakens with time and so our ability to
fight off infection low-grade
inflammation increases raising the risk
of things like heart disease disease and
dementia our brain function declines as
do our senses like eyesight and hearing
and as early as 50 bones get thinner and
weaker muscle mass is lost and it's
harder to rebuild but is this all
inevitable Steve Horvath is a Pioneer in
aging science aging is not the same as
rust accumulating on a car it's not just
breakdown but rather there are processes
that can be manipulated you can tweak it
in certain ways I interpret aging as a
software error could that Insight
explain why Tech Titans of Silicon
Valley have been piling into aging
science Steve Horvath is leaving
Academia to join a new startup with
backers including Amazon's Jeff Bezos
other Bay Area companies are using big
data to unpick the science of Aging
each of these dots here is a molecular
entity like a protein or a small
molecule a metabolite that circulates in
your blood bio age uses computer power
to sift through biological samples from
more than 10 000 people looking for
common factors in those that live the
longest healthiest lives and they found
some promising targets so there's a
protein called Apollo that circulates in
your blood and we saw that people
middle-aged people
with higher levels of apron in their
blood were living longer with better
muscle function and better cognitive
function as they aged so we gave this
drug to really old mice and we showed
that it can improve their muscle
function their drug is already in human
clinical trials but what's the ultimate
goal living forever what we're really
addressing here is the gap between
lifespan and health span so lifespan is
how long you live Health span is how
long you're healthy and right now in
most developed countries there's a
20-year Gap
silicon Valley's pursuit of Aging could
be seen as the uber wealthy trying to
hack their own mortality but another
view is a new frontier that will ensure
Millions enjoy healthier old age and
save Society trillions treating the
diseases that come with it Tom Clark Sky
News San Francisco